[Music]
sometimes you're not trying to persuade
the person mean that that people think
you're trying to persuade what you're
actually doing is trying to persuade
lots of other people at the same time
I've spent my whole life as a as an
educator of as a scientific educator at
Oxford and at Oxford we have rather
unique system the tutorial system where
every student gets a one-hour one-on-one
tutorial each week with it with a tutor
and I had this as an undergraduate which
I absolutely loved and then throughout
my career I was a tutor so I would have
student after student after student
coming into my room spending an hour
with me they would produce an essay we
would talk about it and I would be
trying to we would have a conversation
so I got very practiced in the art of
persuading people of scientific things I
think this may show itself in my writing
the discipline of putting yourself in
the shoes of the reader of the other
person asking yourself all the time what
could be misunderstood here in what way
might my might my words be misconstrued
how would how can I get this this person
is not taking is not really getting it I
can see it from their face at their
puzzle maybe an analogy would help maybe
a metaphor would help so I suppose the
only general thing I can think is put
yourself in the position of your
audience try to see where they're coming
from sympathetically and argue your case
in a way that should resonate with them
there is a difference between persuading
a single individual which is what I was
talking about in the case of an Oxford
tutorial and persuading a whole audience
who are say reading a book or listening
to perhaps a radio program where I mean
sometimes I've done quite frequently in
America I've done shows where there's a
phone in and people phone in and ask me
questions or I have an argument with me
and there I have sometimes given up I
have to confess this I've done sometimes
given up on the quest
to persuade the person who is arguing
with me I might regard them as a lost
cause but I'm conscious of the fact that
thousands of other people are listening
in and the way I handle my argument with
the one person who maybe say a young
earth creationist who is beyond
redemption clearly it isn't even going
to believe anything I say nevertheless
by the the method that I argue was them
may be a total failure as far as
persuading them is concerned but
nevertheless may persuade thousands of
other people who are listening in
[Music]